well he's clearly got a lot on his mind
um that first half hour of the speech
railing against the west but all of the
talking points we heard there and heard
Again In that clip
um are ones that we've heard really
before that this is an existential
battle for Russia that Russia needs to
defend the motherland against the
marauding evil West who is out to
destroy it that Ukraine is not sovereign
but uh interestingly saying that um the
Ukrainian people were being used by the
key of regime and by their Western
Masters as cannon fodder which is
obviously one of the uh phrases that a
was used by a lot of protesters here
when mobilization happened we are not
cannon fodder and there has been
discussed when you look at some of the
terrible Slaughter really on both sides
but also in the Russian casualties
around towns like bakmut at the front
line Wagner mercenaries a lot of them
prisoners being sent in for the
slaughter that phrase cannon fodder
being used across a lot of the Russian
military blogs now President Putin using
it in relation to the Ukrainian people
themselves let's just remember who is
bombing Not Just Energy infrastructure
across the country but entire towns like
Mario Paul like bakmut like a kharkiv
like Kiev still
um uh that is Russia it is not the west
and then we had for longer than an hour
a lot of discussion about how to support
people involved in the special military
operation how to keep the economy going
how to help people in this country
interestingly what he said about those
people who have made money in the west
who had educated their children in the
west and I can assure you that there are
plenty of people sitting in that room
listening who still educate their
children in the west and have
um uh children living in the west some
of them very important state figures but
his
um line to them really was the West will
only treat you as Western citizens is
important that you focus your attention
your resources if you have any left and
your energy on trying to improve things
within Russia he talked a lot about
restructuring the economy how to ensure
that it has a a future given all the
pressures that the economy faces it all
sounds well and good if you forget the
fact that hundreds of thousands of the
sort of brightest and best of Russian
scientists Russian I.T Specialists
Russian Business Leaders have left the
country so he's right that he needs some
pretty fiercely good Minds to try and
keep things going as sanctions make
things much more difficult for Russia
over the years ahead we've had some
impressive work from some of the leaders
of the central bank for example
of Russian Finance to try and keep
things pretty stable over the last year
and they've succeeded in doing that far
more than Specialists might have
imagined and Vladimir Putin pointed for
example to the fact that inflation he
says in Russia is now at just four
percent compared to other Western
countries where he said it was closer to
20 percent so I think a lot of this
speech was about trying to reassure his
people that this is a difficult
situation
um but they must rally together they
must Focus their attention on
um you know Innovation within the
country uh that he has good plans for
the future but this is a country and an
economy that needs radical restructuring
that I'm not sure a 70 year old KGB man
um knows quite uh what to do he's right
that it needs those kinds of measures
whether they will be implemented anytime
soon are a very very different story but
uh this was a long long speech we'll go
out onto the street soon to see how much
of it
um uh really has been sort of absorbed
by the Russian people but I think the
message that he wanted them to hear was
that first half hour when he basically
said this is an existential fight you
need to be with us the Wester out to get
us and we will continue to fight and
fight hard